welcome to this video playing for pony
full for me am i screwed this up a
number of times this is a Hong Kong yeah
I'm okay the flag I mean has screwed up
four out of five i recently lost the
game against him and he's got a high
rating I usually is lower rated so since
he had a good one the classical Kings
Indian yeah the IO net check with before
yeah I don't know night h5 that well so
I'm going for that that line here which
I also don't know well yeah it's been a
long while since I've studied the Kings
Indian in some in some detail that is
really worth mentioning that's not
really the greatest way to play this
ever
well it's got nice position here on the
queenside but maybe it is still
relatively solid I feel like I had this
kind of thing only very recently and
that I didn't like it then and I don't
like it now I could ask why do I repeat
it then yeah probably I don't know
there's probably no good reason maybe I
can get in be sure to d2 we are
activating my city bishop here on g7
it's really really passive I mean I
cannot do anything ever at night oh I
didn't think about that move it looks
interesting though but this is this is
somewhat to slightly night c8 queen aah
yeah i mean the night is only protected
by the Queen so it is from a technical
point of view this is a slightly
vulnerable situation but I don't see how
to I mean I don't see if and how I could
exploit it
what a bad opening rosario yeah how bad
is it if I take this this pawn the only
yeah yes Bishop John Bishop g4 I was
thinking okay that that's not very very
comfortable but if you play such a
demanding opening as the Kings Indian
you probably should know more than I do
what a rotten position group 2a am
a half and who play will move running I
seen a move I wanted to play the bishop
to see seven here but him and when it's
probably as good as any other move he
has ruka eight Bishop g4 those kind of
things you know night is seven years
look a seven Lester is the problem I can
take this sex wait this is hostile ever
I can still take 26 and I here I think
you overlooked that which all of a
sudden gets jackets me back into the
game ha funny it's not great or anything
but I'm somehow still existing more than
I could hope for nye def success the
idea crazy crazy that I'm still in the
game not in not in that bad shape I mean
maybe I'm winning this is Pawn evening
and c6 poem
97 bishop b8 King c79 txt six it looks
it looks kind of awkward but it is maybe
just possible very ugly chess this whole
game I mean from my party I'm not not
from his not from him Jack
this is the kind of game where when you
avoid you're really asking yourself why
is this happening yeah like has done
everything wrong and then somehow
somehow white is still not winning kind
of weird young okay 97 bishop age six
chicks I can go text eggs can take f6
but I will go all the way to the sea
pawn and I could have played g5 but
didn't like that don't like that that
much yeah here i can go f5 I thought oh
he can no I cannot yeah if five is ok I
guess so what now closing it down with a
form it looks awkward but yeah still
this is the way to avoid that I have
direct porn weaknesses it looks
ridiculous a little bit in terms of
structure of it I'm getting here hi
morning check
Bishop to da it would be good I get this
end Bishop c7 to the am
ask that Bishop g5 takes takes Bishop
takes h7 King g7 trap set this is one of
the ugliest games i can remember really
this one yeah flat for the bishop oh man
what a game check check it must be
terribly frustrated I understand that it
was just a terrible game that I played
him and somehow somehow he didn't win I
mean a treaty don't know why like for
fun time yeah well this was really
really bad and so ugly Wow yeah I don't
know how to play that here I know that
this is some something this is like a
line yeah and to think 97 how do they
play it I it's rookie adia looking yet I
think it's the idea to play c5 this is
one move this isn't this is a lion right
yeah this kind of thing okay now I
remembered after the game yeah this this
was just really really really bad and I
had this just recently maybe I get the
same player here black is just in
trouble and you've got those weak pawns
and you have no count to play whatsoever
absolutely absolutely unacceptable this
position the computer is not even hating
it that much but 27 seems to be a better
yeah it is better this is this is really
really awkward Plus almost two here and
now Bishop g4 wins this this kills me
this kills me and now I cannot prevent
drug a seven and c7 and yeah after that
I'm still somewhat alive and here I
really alive I mean it seems that the
worst is over really as ugly as it looks
but it doesn't seem to lose out right
and here I mean all of a sudden I have
those ideas to Jack get to the porn and
it's it's a it's still a draw probably
or draw ish because it has this
discounted chances yeah but here ya hear
I really think he should take and open
the position for the two bishops but you
didn't do that he allowed me to play a
form i know that it looks awkward but I
have this idea and if I can somehow get
this Bishop back into the game I'm
really just a pawn up so I know I mean
after that I really have some hopes yeah
he has come to chalet though against the
pawns him computer is still owned equal
I mean I really have such ugly pieces
the bishop I mean here of course i can
draw with taking on g5 yeah but i didn't
i didn't want that yet and thought i
might have chances to play for a win and
ultimately it was materializing
here yeah this was a little trick I saw
that he cannot take on age seven but she
did yeah and now it says honey it has no
square to go to and yeah this is this is
especially funny I thought this is good
yeah it's attacking this and if you take
my winning the the bishop so this was
this was losing a piece yeah yeah okay
that was certainly frustrating
experience I really played the opening
nauseous Lee but somehow he didn't find
the one or two moves that would have
killed me okay thanks for watching